hello again friends before we get
started i want to thank the sponsor of
this video this video is brought to you
by babel babel is the number one
language learning app in the world with
over 10 million subscribers worldwide
and one of the things that makes babel
great is not only are there lessons
built by over a hundred language experts
but they're voiced by native speakers
not
the robot you know the voice yes see
that voice it's not that which i think
is important when learning a language i
mean among my travels when i've gone to
another country hands down the thing
that makes me feel the connection to
that place and the people the most
is the language when you when you're
there long enough to learn the language
even if it's just please thank you hello
goodbye when you're speaking with
someone
in their native language you feel the
connection it's a palpable real thing
well and the food food and language it's
a beautiful cycle of perspective and
connection it's a cycle
that can start here so click the link
below to get up to 65
off your babble subscription and thank
you very much to babel for sponsoring
this video
i do appreciate it or muchos gracias
that's better all right now let's talk
about the new episode of the office
be honest with me how many people said
that how many people made that joke at
the beginning of their one division
video this week
a lot of things so in terms of the
television show within the television
show but to them it's not a television
show it's a television show within
reality
we have hit full office even the intro
was the office i mean it was different
than the office in that
under pressure eyesight's baby kind of
way and as always spoiler alert for this
episode of one division that would be
one division episode seven so after last
week the hex the the bubble reality
expanded to save
vision from getting vaporized and people
in my comment section i didn't even
think about it we were like oh
you imagine if that was a human and
their bits were getting sucked back i
was like
i don't even think about that i just
kind of like kept it division because
like oh he's
linked to that reality in a way that is
just it pulls him back in but yeah
imagine if a civilian left be like a ren
and stimpy episode you know where it's
like the skin comes
folds back you see the brain in the
skull that would scar the children i
found it interesting
that all the sword agents are clowns is
that marvel studios trying to say
something
wanda trying to say something or agatha
trying to say something government
agents becoming clowns to all
individual agents out there it's not i
don't have anything against you
it's just the government part
clowns but the reveal of reveals was
actually a really
it was a lot of reveal really fast in
this episode wanda's like where are the
kids and agatha's like oh
they're probably sleeping at this point
we all knew something was up with agatha
or agnes well her real name's agatha but
she's been agnes
she goes down to the basement i can only
describe this place
if constantine and zatanna had a [ __ ]
pad
for the amusement of mephisto who had a
collar around his neck
and that collar was on a leash being
held by trigon
it's this place this place was just it
just looks like
every dungeon of witchcraft you've ever
heard about so now that i said it
i'm wondering would trigon be holding
the leash of mephisto or would mephisto
be holding the leash of trigon
marvel dc fans go keep it civil i know i
crossed lore
that's what we do here it's like the
whole thing is like who would win in a
fight dumbledore gandalf
gandalf so big reveal agnes was like i'm
actually
agatha harkness which is funny because
this whole new intro happens with her
this whole jingle it was like oh i got
the harkness you didn't see her coming
you didn't notice her or something like
that i was like i don't know
a lot of people in my comment section
definitely called agatha harkness when i
was going on my theories of
live octavius like with the confidence
of a thousand sons people called it so i
mean
it wasn't not obvious to some people so
we have who
what when where don't necessarily know
why or how
unless the how is well because magic of
course but why
at that point some of the running
theories are well the more wanda
does the more she expands this thing the
more
magic she manipulates agatha's basically
sapping energy from her sapping magic
for some odd reason i don't know if it's
charging her like a battery
basically sounds like what reverse flash
was doing in flash
also i'd like to know why tv shows like
what's the deal with tv
shows why is why is it sitcoms did
agatha do that because she was like i
don't know
it's neat or did agatha make a bubble
and then wanda was like well i'm gonna
do
shows i don't know it's neat either way
i'd like a good reason for it to happen
we'll see if they give that but now that
the proverbial cat is out of the bag
is that gonna keep going or is it like
nope we're breaking the tv show thing
and that's not happening anymore and
what's gonna happen
to this hex this bubble reality don't
know one thing i do know
i really love monica rambo which when
she clawed her way through
the threshold you start seeing some
things happening with her too
that's not why i like her i like her
because she's just she's a [ __ ]
awesome hero you know she has that hero
mentality she has faith in wanda she's
constantly
trying to get to one she's not riding
wanda off as just this lost cause like
some of her superiors are it doesn't
matter i gotta save wandy you know she
has that
hero spirit but yeah good episode fast
reveal at the end that reveal could have
been stretched out for an entire episode
in and of itself but it's coming to a
head and i can see an
ending of this whole thing where we all
just kind of weep with wanda
because behind this whole like magical
powerful being
is a person who just wants the happiness
that she had
with her boyfriend for those two years
that they stole
just that's sad all right so one
division episode seven have you seen it
watch do you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more
click right here to see more